Symonds get into last known footage of
us alive
[Music]
hello and welcome to the vlog where I
try and work out what the hell to do
with the PhD as you might noticed I'm
not on my studio I'm actually in
Edinburgh I'm on holiday here with pixel
girl and we've lived on separate flights
she's funding from Cambridge iPhone
Bristol and I need to pick her up
[Music]
so we are in Edinburgh on a quick little
holiday I'm here with pixel go I'm going
to show you a flee as possible to
minimize my editing work we just had an
amazing breakfast loot blue dot you know
if you're in Edinburgh highly recommend
luodans so this holiday is basically
going to be us doing very little just
bring a little bit cultural and
generally not worrying about work
because I always have a go at pixel girl
for working too much and she always has
a go at me for too much so that's next
week you go in the castle yeah don't go
in the castle oh look it's that Hogwarts
boy
look at all these chickens so fun fact
we nearly went on a holiday to Gran
Canaria I wanted to take pixel go away
from work warm and sunny we compromised
because she didn't want to go anywhere
too far from home too long like minus 2
degrees now we're gonna go and Disney's
latest interactive ride and Finding Nemo
me impune lattices
[Music]
we found him well that was easy
[Music]
so that was us just doing Edinburgh
Castle
[Music]
just as just a reminder we could have
been in canario so this is the largest
private whisky collection in the world
I don't even know how many bottles there
are I left in The Scream saying how many
bottles there are we just did a whiskey
tasting which is how's yours so it's our
first day in Edinburgh done the way that
we do holidays at least for the past
couple of ones has been to get an Airbnb
so this is our B&B it's very nice little
placement of Edinburgh basically get
really cheap flights get an air B&B and
then yeah you're away so it's a nice
cheap little trip and what we're going
to do tonight is we've got a bunch of
food got like a meal deal from M&S we're
gonna have a quiet night in
and then tomorrow I know if you're sure
we're gonna do we'll make this stuff up
as we go thank you you made our own
restaurant figures it's not nice out
there
so we're carrying a hair salon an
incident happened yet say where
basically I was watching this half
brother it's very nice couple things to
do but we did bring any shampoo or
conditioner with us we picked up two
things amazi I looked for the two
bottles when I was watching and I was
like well that was the conditioners
obviously I'll use this one bottles the
conditioner except what was normal
condition one was extreme conditioner
without even paying shampoo on first
base two extreme extreme condition Pixlr
girl's hair it's the summer that
oscillation was Rober to buy shampoo do
it again we just get a haircut done
holiday there we go
that's much nicer I mean he was lovely
to begin with for the record bloody cold
we're spending a lot of this trip
indoors we're gonna go to the National
Museum of Scotland now
[Music]
it was amazing
[Music]
such a child that's ghost the Scots
let's go sustain because I yeah
[Music]
this feels like an a su exhibit it's
like we trapped a robot it's going for
his mating display or it's against the
book that there's a massive variety of
different family subjects they're going
through here late
loads of that's so cool I feel like if I
was to offer a critique of the museum
here it would be that it's trying to do
too much like the science stuff
downstairs great
there's loads of exhibits here which are
hands-on and getting kids involved
there's also stuff for adults but it's
just like it doesn't feel intensely
curated enough to do all these subjects
you know justice I'm really enjoying it
especially for a free museum this is
amazing oh well there's all extra
physics put up here some of you may have
seen my tweet about this exhibit here
which basically if you tweeted it it
makes music and I kind of went into a
slight delirium after I tweeted it which
is kind of fun
great idea like for an interactive
museum piece so I didn't film it because
we're having a nice little date thing
we just went to an Indian restaurant
called dish room which was like Indian
with zoroastrians like Persian
influences we both agreed that may have
been the nicest Ameer we've ever had
like this is as I said to the guy who
played away my dessert I was like my
life is different now I had a chocolate
pudding with a chili ice cream but even
before then we had like cha oh my God
look how pretty this for the whole thing
to assume if you're in if you're in
Edinburgh highly recommendable yeah that
was amazing
I literally can't get it for it now
we're gonna go meet up with the youtuber
he's a bit bigger than me so I just had
a lovely drink with so this is the
second ever time your face that's been
revealed in the internet because this
will be out in a couple of weeks third
third there's a sound from window
production forward but it's a it's a end
great less than ten times that his face
has been on the internet so you're
studying an end
yep apparently he's studying in
Edinburgh and you're doing international
business yeah what you really do is from
an amazing YouTube channel cute oh yeah
of course
okay so maybe only actually only one of
them's actually previous winter
productions mm-hmm
ten minute is 15 minute ish explainer
videos about plays nicely well yeah some
other stuff too perhaps interesting
that's like that that's very low quality
it's like a meme channel except we we've
done a meme channel it's like if you
took an education channel and made it
worse
so it's my channel and then you've also
got the show makers podcast is that it
probably oh and in my personal channel
oh yeah it was your experience with
doing the video with noobest I see yes I
was on a deal with Neil deGrasse Tyson
black bedbug I look very nervous
yeah you threw your back out just before
was your excuse yeah it was my first one
camera video and I'm saying this from
grass toys so don't judge until heavily
but I will leave a link to that video
down below and it's just nice
opportunity you off to America today I
am yeah so you send them off by we're
more than a little drunk right now but
it's very pretty
[Music]
it's the fact that you cute what do you
mean that's not what do you think it was
[Music]
[Music]
so the sun's finally come out and it
reminds me of that Edinburgh is actually
really pretty city which is where we
decided to come here we've not got very
long we're gonna try and get it off the
seat which is well you'll see and then
180 degrees behind
ah the sea so by flying out this
afternoon we do that very long to be
going up here this is what the smells
just like Sun suntan lotion dangerous
pretty so we're just going to walk off
into the sky now why did you climb
amount
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay well I'm badly lit okay so back in
the office actually this is quite a bit
later I have been doing emails and like
getting back up to speed since being
back it's amazing how much stuff builds
up in like three days
it's also amazing how much better you
work when you're not exhausted like I'm
actually I just smash through a bunch of
tasks that definitely would've taken me
longer before the holiday like rest is
important it turns out who knew so I've
got tonight and I've got tomorrow until
the evening
to get a whole bunch of stuff done
including this black holes video which
is I'd say 60 70 percent edited a lot of
the ground works been done times got to
finish it off because I've only got this
period of time because tomorrow I'm
going off on a stag do it's gonna be a
very very geeky stag do
[Music]
so in sharp contrast to yesterday and
well every other day this week which
it's been nice and relaxed there has
been so stressful my legion grow glowing
computer behind me is currently
rendering the most recent episode of the
wiki cast which I've just edited in the
biggest rush three people two hours not
a problem it's fine it's fine
in addition to that I've also edited 80%
now of the science video the black holes
video again I could have slapped it
together and released it which would be
better for me and I'm you know i know
that my sponsor doesn't mind you know
just take as long as it takes to make a
good beer I know they'd rather have
something out but you know I'm not gonna
put something out I'm not happy with so
taking my time with this stuff for that
but I think it's really good I've
actually saved it more in the Edit than
I thought I would actually like I change
the script around as you saw in the last
vlog loads but cameras really high but
I've also saved it in the editing and I
found a few things were saying oh hang
on oh just move that around a little bit
I cut that section it's much more
streamlined than it was I think it's a
much much stronger video but it's not
done
it isn't even rendering this is the the
wiki cast that's that's rendering so now
I've got a few minutes to pull some food
down me and pack and now I'm getting on
a train to London
I seem to have an entire train carriage
to myself
you think people that want to go to
London
[Laughter]
so I just got in I just come in but just
past midnight and this is the birthday
boy here even though it's past midnight
he was like just get immediately started
having look at my miniatures so it's
begun already this is gonna be the next
two days I'm so excited so where have
these been living for the past like 10
years in my bedroom in this box in this
box are this these have barely seemed
like a day Wow
they will see more than the light of day
now I'm gonna see the glory of battle
yeah
[Music]
pilgrimage okay so some explaining
probably needs to be done at this point
this weekend was a stag do and for those
of you that don't know that means a stag
do is the party that a groom
traditionally goes on with his male
friends before getting married our stag
Do's normally are activities which are
inherently manly in some way so going
somewhere and getting ridiculously drunk
or going paintballing or going
whitewater rafting something like that
we went to war hello world for those of
you that are blissfully unaware one
world is the kind of global Nexus of the
Games Workshop hobby community and Games
Workshop is this company that's existed
in the UK for decades making a variety
of things but the most famous is the
tabletop game Warhammer so this is tiny
miniatures any fights battles against
each other with a set of rules the each
miniature is worth a certain number of
points and you know each are each person
has a armies that are worth certain lots
of points and there are rules that
determine how those miniatures interact
with each other so it's a lot of dice
rolling to determine whether weapons hit
or weapons cause wounds or you know
armor saves people and it's it's kind of
organized fun basically Warhammer world
is like a physical manifestation of that
hobby it's a place that has dozens and
dozens of gaming tables that are
pre-made with beautiful sceneries you
can bring your miniatures to and play
games on there's a bar there several
stores including stuff that you can't
get anywhere else
I've played Warhammer for quite a long
time I took a bit of a some time off
because of I got a girlfriend and I went
to university but now I have the time to
actually sort of start you know thinking
about getting back into it whereas other
people like my friend Joe who is getting
married and some of his friends from
home they've played it the whole way
through so they had these big armies
which they brought we played a game
using their stuff on the Saturday now
you might wonder why I'm not explaining
this to you from Warhammer world and
that's because what I'm world has very
strict rules about filming yes
says no filming of any kind whatsoever
so what I've tried to do is pepper this
but this this thing me talking to the
camera with stuff from war ham world
that could have been shot anywhere so
it's only using our miniatures it's only
showing us not trying to infringe on
other people because I imagine a lot of
it in Games Workshop is to do it miners
in the background
people who don't give their consent to
be filmed it's just easier to issue a
blanket ban so I've tried to be as
respectful as possible I do realize I'm
technically bending the rules but Games
Workshop the stuff that I film could
have been filmed anywhere I'm trying to
do you a solid please don't see me so he
played a game of Aegis Sigma which is a
new gaming system that I was completely
new to but I borrowed some of their
miniatures and then we were getting
drinks the entire way so we were getting
drinks from the bar and in the bar later
we played a different game which was one
of the the newer ones gladiatorial
combat which was really fun after that
we then went back to our hostel which I
can show you but isn't terribly pleasant
viewing Simon's get into last known
footage of us alive so because this is a
stag do everything's been organized kind
of kind of up on the chief very grateful
for the people who have organized this
we are however we're gonna die because
this is a hostile
[Music]
getting a very Monster Mash feeling
about this place I was just ready feed
us we're gonna go and live on the farm
blood dripped down if there's a drain on
the floor the rooftops here from the
bathroom components
hopefully we'll survive the night we're
gonna go out for a drink I'll see you
tomorrow so Sunday we spent again
Warhammer World which means I can't show
you what we were doing but we were
playing a different game we played a
gigantic game of Warhammer 40,000 which
is the game system that I played and
getting back into and so I had my
miniatures which had been in storage for
years and years on the battlefield in
full glory arrayed against a gigantic
army that Marty had brought of iron
warriors and you know we were basically
just making up the rules as we went
because we didn't have time to look
everything up because the bat was so big
but we had a really really great time it
was the most fun like the geekiest burn
I've hadn't so long just to be like
rolling dice and and taking names I put
these guys down a little bit wrong
looking at the enemy
as I posted on my Twitter I refuse to
apologize for geeky passion this is the
kind of thing that I love doing and I
realized that it's not everyone's cup of
tea a lot of people think that it's
incredibly dorky and I should be ashamed
of doing it but it's it's something that
doesn't do anyone any harm it's
something that I get a lot of pleasure
from and I think it's something that has
a lot of merits to it like their
artistic merits painting the miniatures
there's social mirrors engaging with
other people and playing a game and
having fun and so I don't care that some
people think that it's it's dorky I will
gladly put this in the vlog and if I get
back into the Hobby in a serious way I'm
going to talk about it then I refuse to
apologize for geeky passion and that's
basically what Sunday was all about the
night before by the way we went to an
amazing pub it was an Edgar Allan Poe
themed metal pub so playing metal music
all the time and I think we just missed
the live music but it was like it was
dank in the original meanings of words
it was called the pit and the pendulum
if you're in Nottingham which is where
we were I don't think I've said that yet
and in order to get to the bathrooms in
this place you have to go through a
bookcase there's like a secret door it
was it was very cool eventually though
we had to pack everything up we made a
bunch of purchases of varying amounts in
the in the games workshop store and then
we parted ways and made our ways home
knowing that we're going to see each
other
the following week which is great
because I really like these guys but it
took it took a little while to get home
it's 1:00 a.m. so I guess there's no
Monday but shush still count on us is
Sunday and I just got off my bus came
came home via Heathrow Airport of all
places and got back via a lift two
trains and a bus and in highs so
amazingly quiet if anything you can put
here is my camera failing to camera
because it's so dark even though I'm a
full view there we go I'm really rather
tired I've got a lot to do tomorrow
tomorrow's gonna be a big day of work
I'm looking forward to getting a video
out next week I've also got Joe's
wedding to go to
another trip away but next weeks give me
a lot of work and focus what I do well
I'm looking forward to so I'm gonna earn
this here I'm gonna go and go home what
walk for about half an hour and get back
home and then uh yeah get some sleep
thank you very much for watching the
video I hope you enjoyed it give it a
like if you did and join me again next
episode for a the next installment of me
trying to work out what the hell I'm
supposed to do with this PhD thank you
for watching see
[Music]